pues la situación durante el día de hoy
ha sido bastante tranquila las sirenas
se han vuelto a disparar son un poco la
banda sonora de este conflicto de este
asedio sobre la ciudad de kiev pero
realmente creo que ha sido el día más
tranquilo desde que empezó el conflicto
esto no significa que la ciudad viva una
situación de normalidad nosotros hoy
hemos salido hemos estado caminando por
la ciudad y hemos visto que la policía
al ejército y los civiles armados siguen
en esa situación de gran nerviosismo
hemos visto detenciones de presuntos
sospechosos de ser colaboradores de los
rusos detenciones en algún caso también
violenta o de todas formas registros
seguramente violentos algunas calles
están cortadas y también se empiezan a
ver los restos de los bombardeos que han
ocurrido en los pasados días en
particular hemos visto
un edificio un edificio que aquí ha
generado mucha polémica porque en un
primer momento se dijo que había sido
bombardeado por los rusos y luego esta
versión fue parcialmente desmentida y la
particularidad de este edificio es que
se trata de edificio residencial la otra
noticia como comentaban ustedes es que
se ha reimpuesto un toque de queda pero
en este caso no será más del toque de
queda que hemos vivido en los días
anteriores sino será un toque de queda
nocturno exclusivamente empezará a las 7
de hoy y terminará a las 8 de la mañana
de la mañana de mañana con lo cual
también podremos nosotros periodistas
seguir haciendo nuestro trabajo